desde ese campo a las afueras de bakud
las tropas ucranianas preparan su
próxima Ronda de cohetes de artillería
de la era soviética su misión resistir
ante el ataque ruso
los ardores nuestra tarea como apoyo de
artillería es contener al enemigo
los rusos utilizan principalmente
Infantería no tienen la misma cantidad
de vehículos blindados que antes sin
embargo tienen mucha Infantería Y ese es
el objetivo principal de nuestro sistema
de lanzamiento de cohetes
Moscú reivindica nuevos avances en la
región oriental de Don Baz la presión
ahora creciente sobre las fuerzas
ucranianas después de que se vieran
obligadas a retirarse de las ciudades
soledad cerca de bakmuth a finales de
enero tras semanas de combates mortales
a unos 30 kilómetros al norte se
encuentra el pueblo de Jean pill
liberado en septiembre los residentes
consideran la posibilidad de un retorno
de la ocupación rusa
si vienen los rusos no tenemos a dónde
ir a dónde huir
la casa de esta mujer resultó dañada por
los bombardeos del verano sigue sin
repararse por falta de fondos
este invierno lo sobrellevaremos de
alguna manera Pero cómo será el próximo
invierno no me lo puedo imaginar no
tengo trabajo ni dinero
las autoridades ucranianas se preparan
para una eventual ofensiva rusa las
próximas semanas el kremlin considera
que backmud es una puerta crítica para
un asalto acromatorsk la mayor ciudad
del Don vas que aún está en manos de las
fuerzas de